dans mon métier qui est la criminologie
on s'occupe essentiellement de savoir
qui fait quoi 70 % des primos auteurs ne
recommenceront jamais jamais mais on ne
le sait pas la première fois puisque ils
sont primau 30 % vont recommencer au
moins une fois ceuxla il faut les
traiter différemment des premiers mais
déjà dès les premiers il faut indiquer
queil faut s'arrêter il y a donc un
besoin d'expression de l'interdit et
d'expression rapide de l'interdit
contrairement à une idée largement
répandue les courtes peines euh où les
mesures éducatives immédiates et rapides
notamment pour les mineurs sont
extrêmement positives elles donnent
d'extraordinaires effets dans les pays
anglo-saxons protestant ou du Nord parce
qu'on intervient vite et on casse le
dispositif rapidement il reste 30 % ces
30 % faut les traiter évidemment avec
des mesures renforcées et ensuite on a
environ 5 % qui produisent 50 % de
l'activité criminelle vous pouvez pas
les traiter comme les 70 autres % ni
même contre les 95 autres % chacun doit
être traité en fonction du niveau de
glissement vieillesse technicité dans
l'activité criminelle et donc faut qu'on
s'adapte au mode opératoire le mode
opératoire c'est le besoin l'envie le
plaisir le besoin j'ai rien et je veux
quelque chose alors c'est un besoin en
général utile c'est celui qui nous a
permis de passer du statut de sujet à
celui de citoyen c'est la révolte
sociale c'est la révolution c'est
l'expression d'une violence contre une
violence plus grande encore celle-là
elle n'est pas du tout contanable elle
nous a permis d'avoir un parlement une
représentation démocratique des citoyen
voilà parfois c'est excessif parfois
c'est même extrêmement excessif enfin
grosso modo l'histoire a montré plutôt
la légitimité de la révolte et du droit
à la résistance à l'oppression qui est
d'ailleurs dans notre Constitution la
deuxième partie c'est l'envie j'ai envie
d'avoir ce que les a ce que quelqu'un a
et n'est pas c'est un effet publicitaire
en général c'est l'effet de la marque
c'est l'effet de la lisibilité d' c'est
l'effet des influenceurs c'est l'effet
de l'inutile et du présent mais enfin il
y a en général il y a pas mort d'homme
et puis le trème élément c'est le
plaisir le plaisir de l'agression de la
possession de la violence sexuelle de la
violence physique de cette augmentation
massive de l'homicide et des
homicidités dont je traite d'ailleurs
dans mon dernier dans mon dernier
bouquin parce que c'est impressionnant
de voir à quel point nous avons inversé
une tendance qui était la réduction à la
violence ultime qui est l'indicateur le
plus stable dans une société he
l'homicide le meurtre l'assassinat nous
sommes passés de 150 homicides à moins
de 2 en 500 ans c'est un gigantesque
succès et en 20 ans nous avons inversé
le processus quand même un petit quand
même un petit sujet qu'il va falloir
traiter or une partie de cette inversion
est liée au trafic de stup pour les
règlements de compte et à l'augmentation
de la violence physique comme élément de
régulation de la vie parce qu'on ne fait
plus confiance à l'état dans sa capacité
d'être un régulateur un intermédiateur
ou un objet répressif